Not surprisingly, a
computer can tell you this in the blink of an eye by simply searching
iteratively for prime factors.
Here's another example. I won't try to read this number.
It's about 3.4 quattuordecillion, and I have to admit that I find it strange that there's even such a name,
but anyway, it has 46 decimal digits and here you can see
its prime factorization.
A computer can also tell you this. I factored this number using the factoring method that's included in the symbolic mathematics
library for Python,
and it took a few seconds, which is not a particularly long time, but there was a noticeable delay.
And certainly the factor N method doesn't find this prime factorization by naively searching for prime factors.
It actually uses a hybrid
of different algorithms including one called the
colored row algorithm, which is an algorithm for factoring
that's more sophisticated than naively searching iteratively
for prime factors, and although that might seem
like a pretty large number,
as an input to a computational problem, it isn't really all that large at all.
It's only 46 characters.
Here's one more example. It's a number with 309 decimal digits.
If we write it in binary notation, it has 1,024 bits and that's
why it's called RSA1024.
The prime factorization of this number is not currently known.
This number comes from the
RSA factoring challenge, which was run by RSA
Laboratories from 1991 to 2007.
They offered cash prizes
for the prime factorizations of various numbers of increasing
size, including this one, which was worth $100,000 US,
but that prize was never collected.
The security of the RSA
public key crypto system is based on the difficulty
of integer factorization.
If you can factor, you
can break the system, and so the purpose of the challenge was basically to track the
state of the art in factoring.
The bottom line is that
factoring this number is beyond our current abilities.
As far as we know, the
problem itself is too complex for classical computers
to solve in practice.
The largest RSA challenge number to have been factored so far, by the way, has 250 decimal digits.
It might be a little bit hard
to read this on the screen, but here's the prime
factorization of RSA250.
It was done in 2020 using an algorithm known as the number field sieve, and it was a collective effort involving tens of thousands
of computers around the world.
Now, let's consider a different
computational problem, which is the problem of computing the greatest common
divisor, or GCD for short,
of two non-negative integers.
Here's a statement of the problem. The input consists of two
numbers this time, N and M,
and we're gonna assume that
they aren't both equal to zero.
The goal is to compute the
GCD of these two numbers, which is the largest integer D that evenly divides both N and M,
and if you think about the
prime factorizations of N and M, what you'll find is that the GCD is the product of all the prime numbers
that divide both N and M raised to the minimum of the powers that appear in the two
prime factorizations.
So it's related to the problem
of integer factorization, but it turns out to be much, much easier
for computers to solve. We can compute GCDs for numbers with many thousands of digits
in the blink of an eye.
It's kind of pointless for me to try to show you examples on the screen because we could fill the
entire screen with digits and we'd still be describing
easily solved instances of this problem.
But if you're interested, follow the link in the video description to the textbook page for this lesson and you'll find code cells
for the sorts of computations
that I'm talking about, including ones that compute
GCDs of large numbers, and you can try them out for yourself.
The question is why is this possible to compute GCDs so easily?
And the answer to that question is that we have efficient
algorithms to compute GCDs.
Among them is Euclid's algorithm, which was discovered over 2,000 years ago, but there are also other
efficient GCD algorithms.
And of course we're talking about classical algorithms here, so that leads to another question.
Could there be an efficient
classical algorithm for integer factorization
that would allow us to factor numbers like RSA1024
in the blink of an eye?
And the answer is yes. Absolutely there could be an efficient classical
algorithm for factoring and currently we don't know any way
to rule out that possibility. All that we can say is that
we haven't found one yet.
For all the classical
factoring algorithms we know, we're still essentially
searching for factors
and that puts numbers like
RSA1024 out of our reach.
Efficient GCD algorithms,
on the other hand, just don't work that way.
They don't search for a
greatest common divisor. They effectively just build
it with a mechanical procedure that's roughly comparable in cost
to multiplying the same
two numbers together, and I'll say a little bit more about this later in the lesson.